[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport genannter familie und das
sind die wichtigsten nachrichten themen
von heute
diplomatischer eklat bundespräsident
steinmeier wollte gemeinsam mit anderen
präsidenten in die ukraine reisen doch
in kiew ist er nicht willkommen
kampf um mario pohl laut unbestätigten
berichten wurden dort chemie waffen
eingesetzt russlands präsident putin
zeigt sich weiter sicher den krieg zu
gewinnen
und trauer um michael degen der
gefeierte schauspieler und zeitzeuge des
nazi regimes wurde 90 jahre alt
der bundespräsident ist zu besuch in
polen und wollte eigentlich gemeinsam
mit dem polnischen präsidenten nach kiel
weiter reisen als zeichen großer
europäischer solidarität mit der ukraine
doch am späten nachmittag dann die
überraschende aussage von steinmeier er
sei in kiew nicht erwünscht aus warschau
natalie steger
betont harmonisch bei der ankunft die
präsidentin steinmeier und duda
gemeinsam an der seite der ukraine
stehen sollte die botschaft sein und
gemeinsame reisepläne nach kiew sollten
besprochen werden doch am ende seines
besuchs ein paukenschlag
mein kollege und freund der polnische
staatspräsident
hat in den vergangenen tagen angeregt
dass wir beide gemeinsam mit den
präsidenten estland lettland und litauen
eine reise nach kiew unternehmen um dort
ein starkes zeichen gemeinsamer
europäischer solidarität mit der ukraine
zu senden und zu setzen ich war dazu
bereit
aber offenbar und ich muss zur kenntnis
nehmen wahr dass in kiew nicht gewünscht
die gemeinsame pressekonferenz davor wie
gewohnt deutschland und polen sind enge
partner wollen sie zeigen doch nun macht
sich du da auf den weg nach kiew sowie
die baltischen kollegen ohne den
deutschen bundespräsidenten der fliegt
zurück nach berlin
fahren wir nach in kiew und in berlin
zunächst zu tim kröger wie ist diese
zurückweisung steinmeiers zu erklären
was hören sie dazu den tieren
also wir hatten hier gerade kontakt mit
dem sprecher von präsident evans gehören
von der seite heißt es derzeit kein
kommentar das ist zumindest der stand
den wir im moment haben wir können also
nur mutmaßen dass diese zurückweisung
von steinmeier auf seine zeit als
außenminister zurück zu führen ist
vielleicht ist es aber auch ganz einfach
so dass sich die ukrainische regierung
vielmehr einen besuch von bundeskanzler
oder scholz gewünscht hat ganz einfach
deswegen weil urlaub scholz wirklich
entscheidungen treffen kann
beispielsweise wenn es um die
unterstützung der ukraine in diesem
krieg geht also wenn es beispielsweise
um waffenlieferungen geht seit dem
beginn des krieges waren bereits mehrere
hochrangige politiker hier in kerth
grundsätzlich sind solche besucher also
durchaus erwünscht weil sie eben zeigen
dass die ukrainische regierung solche
treffen noch durchführen kann dass sie
das heft des handelns noch in der hand
hält und solche treffen seitens der
besucher eben auch sagen wir meinen es
ernst mit der unterstützung
die einschätzung von tim kröger aus der
ukraine beginnt direkt weiter zur theo
koll nach berlin wie reagiert man in der
hauptstadt auf diesen
erforderlich betont unaufgeregt ein
regierungssprecher eben nur knapp und
schriftlich erklärt deutschland gehöre
zu den entschiedensten unterstützern der
ukraine und auch der bundespräsident
bezieher klar und eindeutig stellung auf
seiten der ukraine aber das ist
natürlich nur die offizielle reaktion
dahinter gibt es schon ziemliches
entsetzen hier über diese eigentlicher
doppelte ohrfeige durch die ukrainische
führung einerseits ist es ein schlag
gegen die person steinmeier dem jahr
vorgeworfen wird als langjähriger
deutscher außenminister zu enge
beziehungen zu russland gehabt zu haben
und dass er mit seiner diplomatischen
arbeit der ukraine geschadet hätte aber
es geht dabei natürlich auch gegen das
deutsche staatsoberhaupt und damit gegen
die bundesrepublik insgesamt also mein
eindruck ist im moment dass man auf
diese weise die deutsche politische
hilfsbereitschaft nicht gerade steigert
und die eben erwähnte gewünschte kiew
reise des kanzlers scheint mir damit
auch absehbar vom tisch denn er viele ja
damit an dem auch geladenen
staatsoberhaupt in den rücken dankeschön
theo koll
drei deutsche parlamentarier dagegen
wurden heute in der ukraine willkommen
geheißen die
ausschussvorsitzenden michael roth spd
marie agnes strack zimmermann fdp und
anton hofreiter von den grünen trafen
sich in lembeck mit ukrainischen
parlamentariern alle drei hatten zuletzt
mehr tempo bei waffenlieferungen
gefordert
gerade in mariupol werden waffen zur
verteidigung dringend gebraucht
befürchtet wird eine russische offensive
um die belagerte stadt einzunehmen die
straßen seien bedeckt mit leichen sagt
der bürgermeister mehr als zehntausend
zivilisten seien tot vielleicht auch
20.000 lena sünder bruch in mariupol
graben rettungskräfte in den trümmern
nach opfern eines russischen raketen
angriffs in der stadt sollen russische
streitkräfte nun auch chemische
substanzen eingesetzt haben russische
separatisten bestreiten dass auch die
usa und großbritannien können das
bislang nicht bestätigen
wir wissen dass es berichte über den
einsatz dieser waffen gibt aber wir
konnten sie bisher nicht verifizieren
selbst die ukraine präsident selensky
spricht bisher nur davon dass es solche
berichte gibt sie konnten bislang aber
auch nicht bestätigen dass chemische
waffen eingesetzt wurden
neben der hafenstadt mario paul steht
auch archiv 400 kilometer weiter
nördlich weiter unter beschuss im visier
dabei auch immer wieder nicht
militärische einrichtungen wie dieses
krankenhaus das
leben hat sich radikal geändert alles
wurde auf den kopf gestellt wir arbeiten
nach wie vor mit patienten aber die
situation in unserem umfeld und die
bedingungen haben sich geändert sie sind
extrem
weit entfernt ganz im osten russlands
äußert sich heute präsident putin auch
zum krieg und gibt sich siegessicher es
ist offensichtlich dass wir keine andere
wahl hatten es ist die richtige
entscheidung wir haben keinen zweifel
dass die ziele erreicht werden
militärexperten rechnen damit dass
russland in den nächsten tagen mit einer
groß angelegten offensive in der ost
ukraine beginnt sie soll sich von hartz
iv bis nach hessen im süden erstrecken
das kommando hat ein hochdekorierter
general übernommen der die russischen
truppen schon in syrien anführte bislang
hat die ukraine entschlossen
zurückgeschlagen man hat gesehen weil im
angriff der russen auf kiew und drogen
geworden dass die krainer sich mit
verhältnismässig einfachen mitteln sehr
erfolgreich verteidigt haben und dabei
offensichtlich auch mit ihrer
leistungsfähigkeit und mit ihrer kampfes
moral die russen sehr überrascht mit
jedem tag wächst der druck auf putin
erfolge zu präsentieren
die nächste phase des krieges wird wohl
ein showdown in der ost ukraine sein
der journalist an kinzel ist im
kampfgebiet seine reportage können sie
heute abend bei frontal- sehen ob die
ukraine russland noch stoppen kann
darüber spricht bei zdf heute live unter
anderem der ehemalige nato-general egon
ramms um 19 uhr 30 in der zdf- heute-
app und auf unseren social media kanälen
möglichst schnell unabhängig werden von
russischer energie dafür setzt die
bundesregierung vor allem auf
flüssigerdgas
das prinzip man kühlt normales erdgas
runter auf minus 162 grad dadurch
verdichtet es sich auf ein sechs
hundertstel seines ursprünglichen
volumens so lassen sich extrem große
mengen über weite entfernungen per
schiff transportieren einmal am ziel
braucht es dann allerdings besondere
infrastruktur für deutschland ein
kraftakt elisabeth schmidt berichtet
hier am industriehafen staate soll eines
von drei deutschen flüssiggas terminals
entstehen die niedersächsische
landesregierung verkündet heute zwei
jahre früher als bislang geplant
genehmigungsverfahren sollen
beschleunigt und alle spielräume des
emissionsschutz gesetzes ausgereizt
werden wir bauen auch dann wenn die
genehmigung vielleicht noch nicht
komplett erteilt ist ich hoffe dass wir
ende 24 schon fertig sind und damit ein
starkes zeichen setzen für eine
unabhängige energieversorgung in
deutschland in wilhelmshaven könnte es
sogar noch schneller gehen bereits zum
jahreswechsel soll ein gemietetes
spezialschiff wie dieses flüssiggas
aufbereiten 20 prozent der russischen
gaslieferungen könnten so ersetzt werden
ärger mit anwohnern und umweltschützern
scheint aber programmiert diese flüssig
traktoren sind unter störfall betriebe
das sind gefährliche betriebe die müssen
ordentlich genehmigt werden uns da kann
man nicht einfach die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
überschrift überspringen pläne für einen
lng terminal wilhelmshaven liegen schon
seit mehr als 20 jahren in der schublade
jetzt rächt sich dass deutschland anders
als seine europäischen nachbarn bislang
vollauf russisches pipeline gas gesetzt
hat wenn sie abhängig sind von pipelines
dann können haben sie in der in einer
politischen krise keine alternative
möglichkeit schnell flüssiggas zu
importieren
wenn sie aber ein flüssiggasterminal
haben und es gibt probleme in einem
lieferland dann können sie den tanker
irgend noch wo an ein anderes land
schicken gas statt grünes gewissen der
krieg in der ukraine zwingt deutschland
zum handeln langfristig will aber auch
das terminal in stade ln sie durch
grünen wasserstoff ersetzen
unangenehme nachricht für den britischen
premier lange hatte boris johnson
bestritten an den verbotenen lockdown
partys in seinem amtssitz beteiligt
gewesen zu sein nun scheint die sache
klar johnson muss ein strafgeld zahlen
bei den ermittlungen geht es um feiern
während der korona lockt bei uns in den
jahren 2020 und 2021
damals galten strenge kontakt
beschränkung diana zimmermann in london
der premierminister als gesetzesbrecher
kann er damit im amt bleiben
in dieser bußgeldbescheid vor zwei
monaten kommen wäre dann wäre es wohl
auch für boris johnson eng geworden bzw
das wäre sein ende gewesen nun aber
stehen die dinge etwas anders erstens
ist es so dass viele im land finden der
krieg in der ukraine sei ein punkt warum
es momentan nicht der richtige zeitpunkt
sei dem premier zu schaffen und zweitens
sein natürlicher nachfolger der
finanzminister ritchies und wird erst
ebenfalls ein bußgeld erhalten wegen
unerlaubten feiern und des zweiten einen
fetten skandal um seine frau verwickelt
eine extreme reiche unternehmerin dies
bisher zu vermeiden wusste in
großbritannien steuern zu zahlen da
überlegen sich die konservativen zweimal
ob sie johnson tatsächlich absetzen und
das müssten sie tun mit einem
misstrauensvotum auf keinen fall wird
das vor den wahlen im mai passieren
regionalwahlen wenn die mutter bürger
sich über ihren premier dort entlädt und
die konservativen eine schlappe
einstecken dann allerdings könnte es
noch einmal sehr eng werden für boris
johnson klare einschätzung aus london
dankeschön diana
kommen wir zur aktuellen corona
entwicklung in deutschland die sieben
tage incidents ist leicht gestiegen auf
1000 87,2 dem robert koch institut
wurden 162 1790 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages gemeldet 17.600
sieben weniger als vor einer woche
289 todesfälle kamen dazu
außenministerin baerbock ist heute in
mali dort läuft seit rund neun jahren
der gefährlichste einsatz der bundeswehr
in dem westafrikanischen land sind
derzeit mehr als
1300 deutsche soldaten und soldatinnen
stationiert zum einen für eine
stabilisierungsmission der vereinten
nationen sie sollen islamistische
terroristen bekämpfen zum anderen für
eine ausbildungsmission der eu nach
militärputschen und dem einsatz
russischer soll söldner ist allerdings
fraglich ob deutschland die mission
verlängert aus mali patrizia wiedemeier
erst die verteidigung nun die
außenministerin innerhalb kürzester zeit
zu besuch in mali ingo will annalena
baerbock sich vor ort informieren ob der
einsatz der 1.000 deutschen soldaten
hier noch sinn macht jetzt wo frankreich
angekündigt hat das land zu verlassen
die malische armee in einem topf die
zivilregierung zu entmachten und zudem
jetzt mit russischen kämpfern
zusammenarbeitet
da sehen wir ähnliche muster wie das was
in russland was von russland in der
ukraine verübte worden ist und deswegen
ist es ebenso wichtig dass wir als
internationale gemeinschaft so schwierig
die situation hier in mali ist uns all
diesen herausforderungen in den nächsten
monaten stellen trotz schwieriger
rahmenbedingungen will die
aussenministerin den einsatz fortsetzen
die soldaten und soldatinnen fordern
endlich klarheit
andererseits wissen wir ja dass die
franzosen abziehe und große lücken
reißen und entweder entscheiden wir uns
mit unseren partnern diese lücken zu
schließen und für sicherheit zu sorgen
und wenn wir das nicht können dass die
mission leider beendet werden muss nicht
erwarte mir von der bundeswehr eine
klare entscheidung ob wir diesen einsatz
fortsetzen oder für diesen einsatz
beenden die botschaft hier aus mali an
die bundesregierung ist klar kurzfristig
ist nur mit militär kaum etwas zu
bewirken sollte der einsatz verlängert
werden dann braucht es mehr soldaten und
soldatinnen einige hundert und vor allen
dingen aber auch wirtschaftliche und
zivile hilfen ende mai läuft das mandat
für diesen bundeswehreinsatz aus ob er
verlängert wird muss der bundestag
entscheiden kein wunder dass derzeit ein
deutscher besuch dem nächsten folgt auch
die entwicklungshilfe ministerin hat
ihren besuch schon angekündigt
nach new york bei schüssen in einer u
bahn station in brooklyn sind mindestens
16 menschen verletzt worden mitten im
morgendlichen berufsverkehr ist auf
mehrere menschen geschossen worden laut
polizei ist der mutmaßliche schütze auf
der flucht die behörden gehen aber nicht
von einem terroristischen hintergrund
aus
michael degen kennen sie alle er spielte
hamlet genauso wie rosamunde pilcher
rollen und er schrieb wie er als
jüdischer junge die naziherrschaft
überlebte
am samstag starb degen im alter von 90
jahren ein großartiger schauspieler ein
feiner mensch und ein wichtiger
zeitzeuge der ns zeit sagt charlotte
knobloch frühere präsidentin des
zentralrats der juden thomas gonzi
erinnert
sie sind dabei sehr lebt zu werden so
kannten ihn millionen doktor martin
sanders in diese drombuschs eine seiner
bekanntesten und zugleich seine
paraderolle graumelierter gentleman
attraktiv publikumsliebling
seine eigene leidenschaft gilt erst dem
theater faust hamlet und 40 jahre spielt
michael degen die großen helden
ab mitte der 80er traumschiff und
kollegen geht in serie und wendet sich
der tv kamera zu
ein leichtes spiel hier schwer war das
wirkliche leben des gebürtigen
chemnitzers michaels jüdische familie
wird von den nazis verfolgt der vater im
kz ermordet seine mutter und er
überleben in einem versteck niemals
darüber reden das musste er seiner
mutter versprechen jetzt wollen wir ganz
normale menschen sein und
dazu war es wirklich nötig dass man
verdrängte glaubt mir ich glaube es war
nicht richtig heute mit 67 bricht er das
schweigen schreibt biographien und setzt
sich auch als schauspieler mit der shoah
auseinander für seine rolle als
holocaust überlebender in soko leipzig
bekommt er einen fernsehpreis
von einer familie geblieben ist
michael degen ein leben für das
schauspiel und für die erinnerung
wird zum sport zu den deutschen fußball
frauen die seit langem die erste
niederlage im qualifikations runde
hatten sie ja zuvor alle sieben spiele
gewonnen hätten heute sogar bei einem
sieg vorzeitig das ticket für die
weltmeisterschaft lösen können
stattdessen eine knappe 2 3 niederlage
gegen serbien nach einer guten halben
stunde kann eine zaghafte deutsche
mannschaft einen weiten ball der
gastgeberinnen nicht verhindern pollack
völlig frei per kopf zum 1 0 für den
gruppenzweiten aus serbien verdient
bundestrainerin voss-tecklenburg sieht
viele unzulänglichkeiten vor allem in
der defensive nach dem wechsel genügt
den serbien in ein langer ball quer
übers feld auf dem janowitz um die
deutsche abwehr auszuhebeln das 20
vorübergehend hoffnung als lea schüler
ihre kopfballstärke unter beweis stellt
der anschlusstreffer doch wieder ist die
abwehr nicht im bilde und die starke
damjanovic stellt mit ihrem zweiten
treffer den alten abstand wieder her wir
haben das heute in allen belangen was
wir uns vorgenommen haben nicht
umgesetzt im gegensatz zu den serbinnen
die kommen in der tabelle bis auf drei
punkte heran an die deutschen die ihnen
nur noch das 2 3 in der nachspielzeit
durch wasmuth gelingt
zur champions league heute abend bayern
gegen villarreal schwere aufgabe für fcb
trainer julian nagelsmann nach der 0 1
hinspielniederlage
bessere ausgangsposition dagegen für
liverpool coach jürgen klopp morgen
gegen benfica es war ein souveräner 3 2
1 hinspiel sieg von liverpool in
lissabon doch jürgen klopp warnt vor
überheblichkeit
es ist eine gute basis aber wenn
lissabon ein tor schießt ändert sich das
spiel
zu hause im hexenkessel anfield road vor
den liverpool-fans wird benfica es
schwer haben alle spieler der red sind
fit und nach 2019 hungrig auf den
nächsten champions league titel es ist
ein wahnsinnig wichtiges spiel für uns
wir haben gekämpft um uns zu
qualifizieren und jetzt können wir es
uns halbfinale schaffen wenn liverpool
morgen gegen lissabon gewinnt heißt der
nächste gegner von jürgen klopp wer real
oder bayern münchen
missglücktes comeback
den tennis-weltranglisten-ersten novak
djokovic bei seinem ersten großen
turnier seit februar unterlag der serbe
vor in der zweiten runde dem spanier
alejandro davidovitch vor kinder in drei
sätzen djokovic erste niederlage gegen
den
weltranglisten 46 überhaupt
das wassersport
dankeschön was weit draußen sehr schön
mit viel sonne und temperaturen um die
20 grad da zog es viele in die natur
aber auch die innenstädte wir hier in
dresden freuen sich über besucher gut
gefüllte straßencafés gut gelaunte gäste
und das beste erstmal bleibt auch so
morgen wird es noch etwas wärmer
allerdings sind auch einige schauer
angesagt mehr dazu gleich von tally das
heute journal mit marietta slomka um
viertel vor zehn wir alle wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend bis morgen wenn
sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter der hohen luftdruck wird
vorübergehend gestört von diesem tief
bei den britischen inseln es schiebt
diese front zu uns und die löst morgen
dann im nordwesten zum nachmittag hin
einzelne schauer und gewitter auf sonst
kommt hier warme luft und saharastaub
mit in der nacht ist es klar vor allem
in den östlichen landesteilen sonst
funkeln auch mal die sterne aber es sind
hauptsächlich hohe wolkenfelder und es
wird trocken bleiben und die
temperaturen sinken auf null grad
richtung vogtland und 10 grad im westen
deutschlands generell ist die kommende
nacht deutlich milder als die davor und
morgen dann im tagesverlauf erst einmal
viel sonnenschein und dann bilden sich
im westen schauer und auch gewitter die
allmählich nordostwärts ziehen sonst
kann der himmel auch mal trüb sein durch
saharastaub bei höchsten temperaturen
von 15 bis 16 grad an der nordsee sonst
aber häufig über der 20 grad marke 23
bis 24 grad bis zum oberrhein runter die
nächsten tage am donnerstag schauer und
gewitter die weiter durchziehen 12 bis
22 grad und ab karfreitag ist es vor
allem im norden kühl aber häufig gibt es
sonnenschein ein schöner abend